I think it's a mix of both and I think
that that represents the future of what
the mixed capitalism kind of model is.
The State Ism that Europe has always
practiced,
where corporations and the government
are very much in collusion.
And what Asia has learned to do and does
itself at Korea and Japan and China are
doing is something that basically if you
take European economies and Asian
economies together,
it puts us in the minority of players
who have been practicing real,
genuine,
free market sort of practices and
economics in the last decades.
So I think we're going to learn to do
things their way rather than vice versa.
That speaks to a broader critique of
globalization,
which is that we don't be,
countries don't want to have unmanaged,
unfettered globalization.
They want to regulate,
uh,
they want to have capital controls.
They want to direct and channel foreign
investment in certain ways,
uh,
to serve their own national needs and to
build their infrastructure and so forth.
Um,
that is the model that is prevailing now
in Asia because it's proved to have
great payoffs.
Whereas the free market model is what is
blamed correctly or incorrectly for the
Asian financial crisis.